jean charles marchiani c'est l'homme de
l'ombre de charles pasqua ancien agent
secret devenu conseiller ministériel
puis préfet de la république
c'est un personnage très controversé
sulfureux pour les uns mais pour
d'autres un homme providentiel c'est lui
qui avait obtenu la libération des
otages français du liban en 1988
caroline since et yvon godin pour roger
auque journaliste indépendant sur les
terrains de guerre jean charles
marchiani est avant tout l'homme qui l'a
sauvée des griffes du hezbollah libanais
c'était en novembre 87 les otages roger
auque et jean louis normandin d'antenne
2 sont libérés après un an et deux ans
de captivité dans les minutes qui ont
suivi ma libération à beyrouth je suis
tombé nez à nez dans une des voitures
blindées de l'ambassade de france
avec ce personnage ans charles jean
charles marchiani qui s'est présenté
tout de suite en disant qu'il était
l'envoyé spécial de charles pasqua et
que c'était lui qui négocier la
libération des otages français au liban
cinq mois plus tard les trois derniers
otages français au liban sont à leur
tour relâché par le hezbollah
après trois ans d'intenses négociations
mission réussie grâce aux méthodes
marchiani maintenant c'est monde le
savait secret n'hésitez pas à prendre
des risques nous n y risquer sa vie en
allant dans la banlieue sud de beyrouth
en allant des dossiers directement avec
les islamistes du hezb aulas pourrait y
avoir des informations sur les otages et
pour renégocier d'entre libération un
autre homme de l'ombre à contribuer à
ces libérations
iskandar safa influent homme d'affaires
libanais il a versé 9 millions d'euros à
jean charles marchiani
hier le juge courroye a interrogé
marchiani sur ces commissions occultes
que récompenses telles le juge soupçonne
marchiani d'avoir été grassement payés
pour services rendus dont les dossiers
qui le rattrape aujourd'hui c'est
surtout le milieu des marchands d'armes
et ce qu'on appelle les intermédiaires
qui sont ces réseaux jean charles
marchiani rencontre au milieu des années
iskandar safa qui est l'héritier d'une
grande famille libanaise spécialisée
dans le commerce international des
grands marchés des arts mais pas
seulement
et mme arkani est devenu intermédiaire
avec iskandar safa dans toute une série
de marchés et y compris la vente d'armes
au moyen-orient la justice française a
lancé un mandat d'arrêt international
contre iskandar safa
jean charles marchiani agent secret
homme d'affaires puis préfet de la
république et enfin un homme politique a
toujours été le plus fidèle lieutenant
de charles pasqua
derrière lui c'est tout un système de
liaisons dangereuses et de financement
douteux qui pourraient être mis à jour
charles pasqua est lui aussi dans le
collimateur du juge